what is life beyond death who knows
really we know because we're gonna
explore that today this is a great idea
I'm tweeting you bros tweet me a
location and tweet me a person or an
animal I'm gonna combine these and it
will be a accurate description of what
you see when you go through the tunnel
just to kind of prepare us for what's
inevitably about to happen so I'm just
gonna select these randomly and see what
we get first off we have strict swamp
and Gabe Newell Gabe
yes Lord gaben gaben gaben master race
as for accessories we had sunglasses
princess crown and sexy bra no wait I
can't have that a unicorn horn sexting
Theory number one Gabe sexting wearing
sunglasses princess crown and a unicorn
horn
outside of Shrek's swamp I'm okay with
that
that sounds pretty [ __ ] nice I wonder
who he's sexting alright let's see what
else he brothers come up with oh we got
hell Justin Bieber well that seems
appropriate
queefing okay yes out of all the artwork
I've made this is my project you know I
[ __ ] saved oh my god I have to share
this with you bros what the literal
actual complete [ __ ] my eyes burn now I
I never sleep oh my god let's move on to
the next one next up we have several gun
Sephiroth behind my Donald's tapping I
can see that the [ __ ] things I'm
doing with my life like I don't even
know this is this is what I choose to
spend time on some things you just gotta
do for the internet and that is Rogan
fapping I'm so proud so proud my poor
virgin ass is too he's purple it's a
dildo come on I decided not to do
let's be honest we all see what's that
we have time for one more don't worry
grumpy cat pants ooh space Wow Wow
I don't I'm speechless I my [ __ ] God
what is wrong with me I just want to cry
Oh God I'm so done I never been so done
in my laughs actually I'm not down at
all
all right press this I don't all right I
hope you brothers enjoy watching if you
did hit that like button let me know if
you feel more safe you feel better about
yourself or worse I don't know I will
see you brush in the next one Josh them
brows